how did a musical number almost finish a
member of the jackass squad was johnny
knoxville's evil knievel impression
worth three years with a catheter and
what jackass forever stunts nearly put
an end to a cast member
steven stevo glover has had his share of
stunts go wrong over nearly 25 years of
throwing himself often face-first into
one dangerous situation after another
whether the cameras were rolling or not
in a 2019 video posted to his youtube
channel stevo lays out the history of
his many many broken teeth over the
years while always self-conscious about
his teeth as a boy stevo had never
considered cosmetic dental work until he
needed to in 1995 he jumped from a
balcony at the miami keg party and broke
seven teeth along with his cheekbone and
wrist his first set of crowns installed
in 1997 was stained yellow to match his
existing teeth in 2004 after the
tremendous success of jackass the series
and the first movie steve-o had an
all-new set of teeth put in by 2009
however he had developed a bacterial
infection in his gums that necessitated
a new full set of crowns put in not due
to any wild stunts but rather a lack of
flossing further gum troubles resulted
in yet another set of crowns installed
in 2014 plus dentures to replace two
rotten teeth meaning that steve owes had
a different set of teeth in each of the
four jackass movies you still got those
million dollar teeth that's for sure
in a 2018 interview with vanity fair
knocks for a courses department store
boxing match with professional
heavyweight eric butterbean ash
butterbean he's really strong
films for 2002's jackass the movie
knoxville and butterbean enter a local
swap meet wearing boxing robes and
trunks the two men juked out in the
middle of the sales floor with shoppers
standing by
well dukedown isn't quite correct but a
bean pummels him to the ground waits for
knoxville to get back up allows him to
get in one punch and then pummels him
again knoxville falls unconscious to the
concrete floor resulting in a concussion
vertigo and a severe gash in the top of
his head in the interview knoxville
praises ash's kind spirit and sense of
humor until it was time to put the
gloves on as soon as he put the gloves
on i said something to him he just
looked right through me like he didn't
even know me
it really changed him when he put the
gloves on after nearly swallowing his
tongue knoxville regains consciousness
and even manages a solid zinger
butter being okay
this stunt from jackass 3d begins with
ryan dunn recreating the famous 1980s
maxell cassette tape advertisement by
sitting directly behind an idling jet
engine and getting swept across a field
by the exhaust the crew wouldn't want a
jet engine to go to waste of course so
after done stunt was complete everyone
else takes a turn knoxville dresses as
an old-timey football player and takes a
jet propelled pigskin directly to the
chest eric roner dons a wingsuit and
unsuccessfully attempts to fly away
singer-songwriter and part-time jackass
cast member loomis fool tries to make
like mary poppins via an umbrella and
trampoline but instead is driven
straight into the ground while the film
shows fall getting up from his splat and
appearing to walk it off in reality he
had a broken clavicle and hand according
to the film's director jeff tremaine by
tremaine's estimate it was the most
serious injury suffered by any of the
gang during filming
this is strictly for the purposes of
being educational and a good person so
begins a 2013 video posted online by
stevo featuring a young machine gun
kelly in which the burgeoning pop-punk
phenom gives stevo a smiley face tattoo
on his backside using a bb gun this
segment is only a little over two
minutes long but it's one of the most
excruciating stunts that any jackass
member has taken part in
mgk sits at point-blank range with his
bb gun while stevo bends down in front
of him with his pants pulled down the
impact of the first shot shocks them
both stevo howls in pain or kelly puts
his hand to his mouth and horror the
second shot is presented in slow motion
with two eyes drawn mgk adds five more
shots underneath as a wobbly smile
the final scene of jackass number two is
a large-scale choreographed musical
number featuring the cast singing the
broadway tune the best of times as now
the scene takes knoxville and company
through different styles of musicals and
ultimately ends with an oklahoma style
hoedown featuring knoxville majera and
ryan dunn in classic jackass fashion the
guys take the phrase horsing around to a
whole new level despite the sequences
relative professionalism and polish this
ended up being one of the most dangerous
stunts in the film dunn landed on his
shoulder and developed a nearly fatal
blood clot and while bedridden with that
injury was also diagnosed with lyme
disease
in 2008 knoxville appeared in the
director video spin-off jackass presents
matt hoffman's tribute to evil knievel
he was not supposed to perform a stunt
in the show but knoxville has never been
one to sit out a good time i got to
oklahoma and everyone was having so much
fun and i decided well i want to have
some fun too knoxville's intention was
to backflip a motorcycle despite the
fact that he did not know how to ride a
motorcycle particularly well as he puts
it sometimes when people are explaining
how to do something to me before a stunt
i'm not listening because i just wanna
do the stunt after several unsuccessful
attempts to flip the motorbike up the
steep dirt ramp knoxville let go of the
handlebars too soon just as he had been
told not to do whatever you do do not
ditch the bike right away because if you
go like this and ditch the bike
then it goes 40 feet in the air and
lands on you yeah yeah yeah the bike
spun into the air and came back down
directly on top of him specifically on
his crotch knoxville was rushed to the
hospital and subsequently diagnosed with
a torn urethra for the next three years
knox fell out to wear a catheter the
injury could have been much worse he
told variety in 2022 the doctor said a
couple of centimeters down and it would
have been out of commission but i've had
two children since then so it's in great
working order
jackass is at its best when a simple
task is carried out in the most
outrageous way knoxville and his band of
knuckleheads can imagine such is the
case and lamborghini tooth pull from
jackass 3d
former professional snowboarder danger
aaron needs a toothboard so naturally
the chosen method of extraction is a
length of extra strong fishing line with
the tooth on one end and bam majera's
lamborghini on the other aaron sits in a
dentist chair in the middle of a race
track while majira floors her sports car
in the opposite direction it's difficult
to tell what the most horrifying element
is in this stunt the distinct pop sound
that accompanies a tooth being pulled
from aaron's mouth his screams of agony
and inability to regain composure
afterwards or the fact that the stuns
didn't just pull his tooth but as he
told the willamette weak broke his face
quote all the way up to almost his eye
jackass forever arrives in theaters in
february 2022 after a nearly year-long
delay and a full 12 years after jackass
3d the film is filled to the brim with
guest stars and new additions to the
gang though not all the series original
stars will be returning ryan dunn passed
away in 2011 and bam majera was fired
from the production in 2021 due to his
erratic behavior and substance abuse
issues through it all however johnny
knoxville has been the steady hand on
the oversized shopping cart his natural
charm as host has always helped smooth
over the show's rough edges and his
boyish enthusiasm for making his friends
do stupid stupid tricks is still
infectious nearly 22 years after the
first episode jackass may be mean at
times but it isn't mean-spirited it
helps that knoxville is always willing
to put himself at risk before anyone
else as stevo told gq magazine in 2021
there's nobody else on the cast that's
ever going to roll the dice with their
life like that knoxville rolled the dice
once again in jackass forever nearly
dying in a stunt that involved him
performing a magic trick for a bull
bulls have been a part of many jackass
stuns over the years and seem to have a
special fascination for knoxville he
told gq you know exactly what you're
going to get with balls they hate you
which is great for us the running with
this ball put knoxville in the hospital
with several broken bones a concussion
and a brain hemorrhage was it worth the
damage as always the resulting footage
promises to be both hard to watch and
impossible to look away from
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one